why Hollywood won't cast Brendan Fraser
anymore there was a time when actor
Brendan Fraser was starring in multiple
movies regularly those days are long
long gone where did it all go wrong for
the Indianapolis for an actor let's
count the ways Dudley do-right started
doing so little bombing at the box
office
Fraser had a rough 2010 and that year
may be why he's become persona non grata
in Hollywood in the span of two months
Fraser starred in two box office
disasters the medical drama
extraordinary measures was universally
panned by critics who said that it
belonged on television audiences stayed
home and it earned just 12 million off
of a 31 million budget three months
later Fraser starred in faerie vengeance
compared to extraordinary measures
Barry Vengeance performed about the same
grossing seventeen point six million off
of a thirty-five million dollar budget
unfortunately for Fraser the film was
universally crushed by critics killed
his own comeback Frasier's kid-friendly
action flick Journey to the Center of
the Earth was a surprise hit it became
one of the highest-grossing movies of
2008 burning an impressive 100 1.7
million dollars New Line Cinema one of
the sequel fast but Fraser wanted to
hold out for the originals director Eric
Brevik who was busy finishing Yogi Bear
3d the studio decided to use a new
director and replace Fraser with Dwayne
the rock Johnson on the one hand
Frazier's loyalty was admirable on the
other his timing couldn't have been
worse
Johnson replaced Fraser only months
after ferry vented spawned in theaters a
time when Fraser desperately needed
better work The Mummy franchise limped
on the first mummy movie from 1999 while
not a hit with critics earned a massive
155 million dollars in theaters the
sequel The Mummy Returns was an even
bigger hit grossing a staggering 202
million in 2001 and making it one of the
10 highest-grossing movies of that year
one would think that Universal Pictures
would try to rush out a prequel but
because of various delays the third
mummy didn't arrive until 2008 with a
new director and an almost entirely new
cast
bored by then audiences had grown tired
of the franchise especially after the
Scorpion King spin-off that fatigue
showed in the film's performance it
barely crossed 100 million in the u.s.
signaling the beginning of the end
The Mummy had decayed lackluster
projects some of Frazier's biggest flops
included the live-action adaptation of
Dudley do-right which grossed a paltry
nine point nine million off of a seventy
million dollar budget the bizarre 2001
comedy monkey bone which earned just 5.4
million off of a 75 million dollar
budget and Looney Tunes back in action
which took in twenty point nine million
off of an 80 million dollar budget at
the time Frasier was lucky that he had
the mummy franchise to counter these
flops his weird Golden Globes class
Fraser became the subject of humorous
gifs memes and general internet ridicule
after cameras caught him awkwardly
laughing and clapping while Robert De
Niro was presenting the Cecil B deMille
Award at the 2010 Golden Globes the
three-second long moment had everyone
laughing the night of the ceremony video
remixes including one set to Gwen
Stefani's hollaback girl made it the
stuff of internet legend once the
applicable star of innocuous Hollywood
movies Fraser looked awkward and someone
out of place it's okay Brendan will
still give you an awkward ovation thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
let us know why you think Hollywood's
given Fraser the cold shoulder